foreign
let's go out to Detroit Rock City Home
of Eight Mile and talk to Paul what's up
Paul hey how's it going rocking on man
what are you up to
um not a whole lot um I just want to say
uh thank you for taking my call and
letting me um be on the show with you
you got it man thanks for trusting me
and give me a buzz what's up
um so my question is is I've been
married for 20 years but it feels like
for the last 10 years I've been living
under a rock and I've been oblivious to
things that have been going on in my
house with my wife my relationship with
my kids but at the same time it also
feels like
no matter what I do I have
um goal posts that are moving so
um I'll try my best I'll do things to
make everyone happy but then it was
there was something else that I missed
or something else that I didn't do and
that's causing a lot of
um
communication issues and conflicts in my
household and I'm trying to be the best
person I can be however I keep failing
short over and over and over against two
standard
um against my wife's standard
when you don't want to be the better
person now that way I can support her in
that role I got that that's all I feel
like it's important to put truth on the
table okay
okay like I I I'm not gonna
I don't doubt your sincerity for a
second I think you're a good man okay
I'm gonna start there
okay
um and sometimes it's hard to say the
truth about our partner is like hey this
is actually happening or this person is
really hard to be with or this person
keeps moving the goal posts on me every
time I think I've understood the rules
of the game the rules changed I thought
we were playing basketball and I were
playing football and so it's important
to do both when you say you've been
living under a rock what does that mean
that you're oblivious for a decade of
what was going on in your house what
does that mean yeah so it means like
um I know I thought everything was PG
fine
um you know we had a good relationship I
had a good relationship with my kids and
then it turns out we had
um a miscommunications and my wife is
like listen our youngest one is 17. he
graduates this year after this year
I don't have to stay married to you no
more I can go out on my own we don't
have any kids holding us together we
have nothing it's just a matter of if I
want to be with you or not and that is
scaring me especially when I know I keep
coming up short whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa dude whoa
do I have permission to just speak
honestly and openly
okay is that okay
yes so I'm gonna say some things are
going to make you mad and they should
but I feel like I need to say them is
that okay
absolutely I don't know that you've been
living under a rock as much as your wife
has been lying to you for 10 years
okay I don't know that you're failing I
can't if I if you tell me we're playing
basketball and I show up with my short
shorts and my tall socks in a basketball
and I start dribbling and putting it in
the net
and
somebody comes with a football helmet
and hits me
I'm not failing at the game of football
we're playing basketball
okay I don't think you're failing at
some standard it sounds like your wife
doesn't want to be married to you
and she's writing out her clock
and there's nothing you can do if you're
with a partner that doesn't want to be
with you anymore
okay is that fair tell me I'm wrong
nope that I I get that that's fair who
in the world would look at their spouse
and say
ha now that the kids are gone now it's
up to me
what
as opposed to hey we got one year left
with knucklehead number three and after
this you and I get to recreate this
whole thing
we get to imagine a life we haven't had
for 20 years 22 years however long old
your oldest kid is
yep and we get to do whatever we want
whenever we want minus College tuition
payments
right right
and your wife chose that moment to
weaponize that that that moment of
vulnerability
yeah I didn't look at it that way I
always figured yeah you're so beat down
for so long that every time there's a
problem you immediately say I'm so sorry
what did I do
I'll fix it I'll make it right
yeah absolutely that's what I try to do
and the fact is is she didn't want me to
fix it she wanted me just to listen and
hear her and I haven't done that I've
always went to fix it mode that's fair
that's fair
so I know I've made plenty of mistakes
on the communication side where I didn't
hear or I didn't listen well and she did
too she didn't tell you my wife gave me
the gift about seven years ago
stop trying to fix my problems I'm
smarter than you I just want you to
listen to me
will you be my wife has said that stuff
and I didn't listen Okay that's my
problem there you go then you're a
knucklehead
but absolutely so here we are
is it too late for me is what I because
I've been trying my hardest off I speak
to counselor I've been listening to your
podcast I've found um several other
podcasts none of what I have to say what
other podcasts have to say or what your
therapist has to say matters
okay the only thing that matters is
can you sit across from your wife
and say are you interested
and building the back half of our life
together into something incredible
or do you want to leave
if you tell her I'm all in
and she says I don't I'm done I've been
dreaming of this moment for six years
I just went into a quiet phase I just I
just locked myself in ice for six years
to ride out the clock
okay
but all these other voices unless your
wife has given you a very clear list
here's what I need if you want to stay
married to me
here's what I need
and by the way you get to say what you
need too
all right understood when's the last
time you did that
um
I had a conversation with her about two
weeks ago it's like okay what do you
need and then she laid it out she
listened I need to spend more quality
one-on-one time with the kids more time
with her and we started doing some of
those tasks how's that going
um I think so far they're going good
um I travel a lot for work just last
night we spent a bunch of time over on a
video phone going over some
um
you know these these cards that we got
and we had good conversations so I think
it's starting I'm just not sure
could it be that you are unsure of your
worth outside of your utility
I asked that in kind of a nerdy highbrow
way I'm sorry yep nope nope nope yes
yeah it could definitely be because you
know
this is my whole world here so how old
are you
um I am 42. okay
one of the most common you've been
married for 20 years so one of the most
common questions or conversations I have
with 40 year old men and 50 year old men
behind closed doors is
if I'm not my answers
what am I
and the hardest thing to reconcile is
you wired into your nervous system is
men are only as valuable as the crap
they can do
period
and I reject that wholeheartedly because
it's killing a generation of men
is there a set of skills that a man
needs to learn one thousand percent
no question about it
and
does a man have more value than just the
tasks you can check off the list yes
and it sounds like what your wife is
trying to tell you is
in all of your performing and all of
your trying to get it right
it's like it's like an actor looking for
a script and she's like I don't want you
to be Shakespeare I just want you
okay does that make sense
yeah that makes sense
and so I think when you say what what do
you need
I think it'd be fair to come back and
say hey I've been thinking
the best way I can show up for you all
and give you full presence
exhale real big is to know I've got
value to
and so I'm gonna trust you
that if you want my advice
if you want me to give you like an
answer or to look up directions or
something like that
or look up the mortgage rates or the tax
code if you want that that you'll be
very clear and ask me for it
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
release myself from that responsibility
because you're brilliant
and you're my wife
and I trust you to ask for it and I'm
going to practice just showing up to
listen because we're friends
okay
I guess that's where I've been failing
in the past stop dude
if I showed up to a job
to fix a house and I opened my tool bag
and all I have is a hammer
and all they have to hang the drywall
with is screws
and so I do this job with hammering
screws through drywall
it will be loose and not straight
but I say I did a great job no can I say
I did the best job with a tool I had yes
did I fail no
in fact I may have accomplished
something pretty significant I hung
drywall with a hammer
okay that's pretty dang impressive I'm
not a failure what I do need though is
new tools and new training and I'm
probably gonna have to redo that garage
but
I did a pretty impressive job with a
hammer
you my friend have to stop referring to
yourself as a failure every time you
don't get something right
I guess that's extremely hard to do
because I've been saying that for so
long I know rather than feeling it that
for so long now
and you can't possibly expect somebody
else to love you and to fully plug into
you if you hate you
there's nothing for them to plug into
okay you're an outlet that with no
electricity
you have to love yourself enough to go
to the gym
I love myself so much that I'm going to
be a good Steward of this 42 year old
body
I love myself enough
that I'm going to get a full night's
sleep so I can show up for my kids
one-on-one plugged in I'm gonna close my
stupid laptop when I'm at home turn my
dumb phone off when I'm at home
and if I I don't have a boss that
doesn't believe in home time I'm gonna
quit my job
I'm gonna make it a over the next 365
days I'm going to begin to turn the ship
and get through something new because my
family's not worth losing all that
exactly at 100 I agree with that yes but
what we're doing here is we're not a
failure dude
you have just been building a house with
only a hammer it's pretty impressive
I don't know how you managed to saw all
that wood with a hammer you figured it
out it looks terrible but you did it
right okay yes yep
make it a commitment today make it a
commitment today tell your kids this
will be a fun a fun way to connect with
your kids how old are your kids
um I have
two 23 year olds a 20 year old and a 17
year old awesome how much do you make a
year what's your annual take home
um over a hundred thousand a year great
this is gonna be a fun game
I want you to tell all of your kids in a
phone message
hey guys
I'm realizing that I talk to myself
worse than I would ever let anybody talk
to somebody else
and because I think have thought so
little of myself for so long it's rubbed
off on all you guys
and I'm sorry for that
from this day forward to my 22 and 23
year old kids my older kids
I'm going to send you a check for a
hundred dollars every time you catch me
saying I was dumb or I'm stupid or I
failed that I screwed up
two younger kids I'm gonna send you a
check I'm gonna give you cash fifty
dollars
and come up with something special
between you and your wife
and they will smile and they get to
catch them they get to be a part of
their dad
reimagining his relationship with
himself
and it's going to cost you a couple
hundred bucks and you're gonna quit real
quick okay
so it's a hundred dollars to for my
older kids for any time I say I was a
failure and fifty dollars to my youngest
anytime somebody says something crappy
about their dad okay that happens to be
their dad right
and sit down with your wife and say
I realize
I thought so little of myself for so
long I didn't think I was worth you
loving me
and I thought so little of myself for so
long I thought the only value I would
bring to our kids is a paycheck that
would direct deposit and I'm just gonna
work on the road and get out of the way
so y'all can live a great life because I
kind of suck
and I want you to tell your wife you're
sorry for thinking so little of the man
she married
okay and tell her that you're going to
commit
to reimagining your relationship with
Paul
and that's going to be twofold one of
that is going to be standing in front of
the mirror and you're going to embarrass
the crap out of yourself but you'll be
alone and putting a fist in your chest
and looking at the mirror and saying the
words I love this guy 10 times in the
morning and 10 times at night I love
this guy
and when you say it you're going to feel
your your shoulders clinch up around
your neck and then you're going to
consciously drop them and say I love
this guy
and you're not just going to bark
mantras like Instagram would tell you
you're also going to go to the gym
you're also going to be doing that for
last month yes good and you're going to
get a group of men to hang out with
and if your wife wants to go see a
counselor you're going to go with her to
see a counselor in fact you may ask hey
would you go to see a counselor with me
yep yep yep see what I'm saying you're
going to start not just
spouting out mantras you're going to
start with a whole bunch of tiny little
wins
in route to becoming a guy that you
respect
okay
you get what I'm saying it's both things
yes I get what you're saying absolutely
um what about when I do fail at a task
or something of that nature
okay I do all the time did you know this
very show we had to reshoot the intro
because I screwed it up
that's unfortunate I have a top five
podcast in health and fitness in the
world
and I screwed up the intro because I was
just blabbing on about something that I
thought was funny and Kelly looked at me
and she was like that's clearly not
funny at all
and then I tried to get out of it and I
just made it worse and then I started
babbling
that's what I do for a living I fail
every day
yesterday
I put my seven-year-old daughter's face
in my hands and I said I'm sorry I did
this wrong
and she doesn't even she didn't even say
I forgive you
I didn't say I was wrong for her
forgiveness I didn't say I was wrong for
some sort of approval stamp from her I
said I was wrong because I was wrong
I fail every day Paul every day okay
it's part of Being Human
the test of a man the test of a woman
too but in this case I'm just talking to
a man so the test of a man in this
moment
is are you going to get back up are you
going to own your mistakes and you're
going to go make them right
and the other the person you wronged
they get a say into how you make things
right
okay
and then you go to the mirror and you
put your fist in your chest and you say
I love this guy and then you go do the
next right thing
I guess I'm just afraid when I do go to
ask that question is what if the answer
is no I don't want to be with you in a
year
the way to guarantee that is to isolate
yourself and not ask that question and
try to
sing and dance your way to your wife's
approval okay
maybe you take her out to breakfast and
you say hey
um
I've tried to love you through my
insights and wisdom and knowledge
and I've tried to love you through my
bank account I try to love you through
making sure you had all your needs
submit
foreign
and that's left you feeling isolated and
cold
I'm going to try to love you by being
honest with you by being vulnerable with
you
by telling you what I need what I'm
scared of
I'm gonna practice because I've never
done this before
and so I'll ask you to be gentle with me
and be kind to me as I'm figuring this
out
and Kids when you catch your old man
talking bad about himself I'm gonna pay
you
honey if you catch me talking bad about
your husband will you call me on it like
you would a stranger
and don't try to do this on your own
your wife sounds like she's giving you a
road map
follow the road map and she needs a road
map too
she's told you how to love you I think
it's fair for you to say here's how I
need to be loved in this new marriage
we're building
call anytime my brother thank you so so
much for trusting me and for being
vulnerable I'm proud of you hang on the
line I'm gonna send you two copies to
building a non-anxious life I want you
and your wife to both read them you know
I can build a road map together on how
to build a less anxious house
and in so doing I'm confident you're
going to be able to find some things
that y'all can talk about together
it's going to bring up some new needs
and new wants that y'all can do together
I'm proud of you man
thanks for the call